[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir il y aura 8
milliards d'êtres humains en novembre
2022 selon les nations unies et d'ici
2050 une personne sur 2 verra le jour
sur le continent africain nous irons au
niger l'un des pays les plus pauvres de
la planète avec le taux de fécondité le
plus haut du monde mais aussi celui de
la mortalité infantile parmi les plus
élevés au monde
les motos électriques ont fait leur
apparition au bénin et au togo et avec
la flambée des prix des câbles des
carburants c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour les transports reportage à
suivre dans le journal
et la ministre du bonheur est de retour
chez elle la tenniswoman accueilli en
championnat tunis après sa grande
tournée du grand chelem reportage auprès
des fans sedan jabeur dans ce journal
dans quatre mois la terre comptera 8
milliards d'habitants d'ici 2050
une naissance sur deux aura lieu en
afrique allons au niger l'un des pays
les plus pauvres de la planète et qui
enregistre le taux de fécondité le plus
important au monde sept enfants en
moyenne par femme mais un enfant sur
trois ne survit pas au delà des cinq ans
à niamey la correspondance génaral djiar
le taux de croissance démographique ici
au niger avoisine les 4 % régulièrement
le plus élevé au monde le taux de
fécondité lui dépasse les 7 enfants par
femme la population actuelle du niger
est évalué autour de 24 millions
d'habitants cette population pourrait
atteindre les 30 millions de personnes
d'ici 2030 la maîtrise de cette
démographie reste un sujet très
impopulaire dans une société peu encline
aux questions de contraception et donc
de planification familiale et pourtant
dans la société nigérienne deux des
principaux fléaux qui sévissent en ce
moment sont la malnutrition et la
déscolarisation des enfants je pense que
la manière de sujet de la planification
familiale
a fait son entrée
pas seulement au niger dans quasiment
l'ensemble des pays africains et ça je
pense que au sud comme au nord les gens
font consensus qu'il y ait raté au début
des questions des programmes de
population
puisque il fallait partir de la question
de l'acceptabilité sociale et morale de
la planification familiale mais cela a
été escamoté une erreur de communication
politique qui essaie de rattraper le
gouvernement actuel le président
nigérien mohamed bazoum s'est exprimée à
de multiples reprises en faveur d'une
natalité plus contrôlés dans son pays
une politique qui se heurte aux courants
les plus traditionnalistes de la société
nigérienne mais aussi un taux
d'alphabétisation trop faible surtout
dans les zones rurales en moins de dix
ans au niger c'est plus de 2 millions de
nouveaux pauvres qui ont été
comptabilisés à cause de cette
croissance démographique ultra rapide
trois personnes ont été arrêtées en
afrique du sud après la mort mystérieuse
de 21 jeunes dans un bar informel situé
dans la ville d'east london dans le sud
est du pays l'enquêté est en cours mais
les autorités ont déjà écarté la
possibilité d'une bousculade mortelle
deux semaines après la tragédie les
autopsies et les analyses n'ont pas
permis de déterminer la cause des décès
et on reste en afrique du sud le pays
qui a bien du mal avec les changements
climatiques entre les sécheresses et les
inondations depuis 2016 la province
orientale du cap est victime de
sécheresses successives
aujourd'hui elle craint le jour où il
n'y aura plus tôt le jour zéro risque de
paralyser nelson mandela bay
anciennement port elizabeth la ville de
plus d'un million 800 mille huit cent
mille habitants est désormais rationné
le reportage de caroline dumay et
stéphane carter
dans la province orientale du cap le
barrage jimpo foule n'a même plus le
niveau suffisant pour qu'on puisse en
extraire de l'eau il y encore un mois ce
barrage était pourtant la principale
source d'alimentation de la ville de
port elizabeth mais près de deux
millions de résidents sont aujourd'hui
rationner 50 litres d'eau par jour et
par personne après plus de sept années
de sécheresse la municipalité fait tout
pour éviter le jour 0 le jour où il n'y
aura plus une seule goutte d'eau au
robinet
ce n'est pas encore une situation de
jour zéro mais plus d'une situation
d'approvisionnement intermittents l'eau
est là mais en période de forte demande
la pression de ce fait certaines
personnes dans les parties basses du
système d'approvisionnement alors
profond de l'eau et des partisans
n'auront pas
et c'est déjà une réalité dans certains
quartiers ici on a fermé les écoles et
renvoyer les enfants à la maison cindy
soi explique que ça fait vingt-quatre
heures qu'ils n'ont plus d'eau
ça va ça vient en fait on n'y comprend
rien et personne ne nous prévient quand
vous ouvrez un robinet vous réalisez
plus d'eau à la maison
pour aider la municipalité l'une des
plus grandes ong sud africaine s'est mis
à creuser des puits dans les écoles dans
les hôpitaux ils resteront ici six mois
l'équipe revient tout juste de la
province du kwazulu natal où ce sont des
inondations qui ont détruit les
infrastructures
et partout la démographie est tellement
grandissante que les besoins sont
toujours plus importants route par
rapport aux ressources limitées que sont
les barrages à creuser des puits et la
solution par tous les clients td les
poppers
creuser des puits reste une solution
simple et efficace pour lutter contre
les changements climatiques
en afrique du sud on cherche désormais à
prévenir les catastrophes naturelles
allez je vous emmène au bénin et au togo
où depuis quelques semaines sont apparus
dans les rues des nouvelles motos
particularité elles sont électriques
et/ou
le prix des carburants flambe c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle le transport
est responsable vous savez de plus d'un
quart des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre un chiffre qui devrait doubler
d'ici 2050 dans les pays où le deux
roues et le transport le plus utilisé la
transition écologique passe notamment
par les motos électriques emmanuel sodji
la plus grande ville du bénin est
célèbre pour ses fameux conducteurs en
chemises jaunes appelé keynan langue
locale christian léon zanou exerce ce
métier de substitution depuis cinq ans
mais depuis plusieurs semaines ils
louent cette moto électrique pour son
travail j'apportais conduit ça parce que
bon ça ne prend pas de l'essence
et par rapport
aux pratiques
djoko n'a pas de pièces exposées à
mesure dans ce moteur électrique tous
les 75 km le conducteur sur trois des
changes de batteries pour un peu moins
d'un euro pour la moto que j'ai utilisée
avant je fais au moins dix mille plans
d'économies pas moi cinquante mille taxi
moto électrique devrait être déployé sur
le principe de la location d'ici à la
fin de cette année au bénin et au togo
sans compter celles fabriquées pour le
grand public cela n'intéressait pas de
ceux qui électronique ya 90 millions de
deux roues motorisés sur le continent
africain dont plus de 80% sont utilisés
pour des usages commerciaux et c'est
vrai qu'il y avait déjà cette culture de
l'utilisation du deux roues avec cette
culture du sémillant au bénin et au togo
le béninois chez goom bakary et son
associé le puissant homme d'affaires
d'origine indienne given gupta bénéficie
au bénin et au togo d'une politique
fiscale avantageuse face à l'urgence
climatique en afrique le secteur des
transports est responsable de plus d'un
quart des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre quand on parle de neutralité
carbone
d'environnement s'il n'y a pas un gain
économique pour les usagers il n'y a
aucun moyen de choisir de passer à
l'électrique et c'est seulement dans
saint pons pour amener les gens vous
faire la transition écologique autrement
ce sera juste et des incantations et
sessions quoi nous croyons d'ici à 2023
la holding propriétaire de l'entreprise
qui assemble les deux roues électriques
zéro émission comme ici au togo
installera deux usines de production en
afrique de l'ouest mais déjà c'est une
bataille féroce que se livrent les
firmes chinoises et indiennes pour
opérer le passage à la mouche électrique
la relance du secteur culturel post que
vides au coeur des échanges à conakry
les acteurs de plusieurs régions
plusieurs pays de la sous région ont
rejoint la capitale guinéenne pour
travailler sur des stratégies à mettre
en place pour voir sur et une meilleure
relance on les écoute au micro de malik
a quitté
la culture a besoin de moins la culture
a besoin de de reconnaissance la culture
a besoin de soutien et c'est ce que nous
sommes en temps de mettre aujourd'hui en
place pour valoriser nos sites et
monuments historiques qui sont
aujourd'hui interdiction mais aussi
permettre aux artistes de faire la
création de faire de très bonnes
productions et de très bonne diffusion
si je pense que il est important que les
moins soit encore de multiplier afin que
la culture africaine pu sortir de
l'ornière nous avons vu que plusieurs
pays ont fait des réflexions sur la
préco vite et nous avons remarqué que
beaucoup ont même élaboré des plans de
relance pour l'après coville ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui après cette crise là
c'est vraiment aider les entreprises à
se relever
il est détenteur du record d'afrique 200
m un des espoirs africains pour les
mondiaux d'athlétisme qui débutent
vendredi mais ferdinand o mania là n'a
toujours pas son visa pour les
etats-unis écoutez les néanmoins le
sprinteur kenyan exprimé ses ambitions
pour ces futurs championnats
si je réussis à sortir 1 9 seconde 6 en
oregon ce sera ma plus grande réussite
et puis bien sûr je vais là bas pour la
victoire
si le championnat du monde et remporté
par un neuf secondes 6 ou moins alors ce
sera moi mais s'il gagne par un neuf
secondes neuf alors je suppose que ce
sera une course longue je vise le podium
en passant d'abord par les éliminatoires
les demi finales puis la finale
et on reste dans le sport pour célébrer
avec les tunisiens celles qui l'ont
surnommée la ministre du bonheur la
joueuse de tennis 6e au classement
mondial onze sapeurs de retour à tunis
est accueilli comme une icône après ses
dernières performances reportage de
lille i à blaise et âme dit il
c'est un retour que les fans de jabber
attendait depuis des mois son arrivée
dans son pays natal après une victoire
au tournoi vetea de madrid et une place
en finale dans le dernier tournoi de
wimbledon
du jamais vu pour une tenniswoman arabes
et africaines qui ne cesse d'inspirer
dans son pays et voilà je suis vraiment
très contente que je veux vraiment
envoyer un message assez fort on ne peut
continuer encore plus travailler dur
parce que je commence à savourer
dans le pays le jeu et la personnalité
jabber sont un modèle à suivre pour de
nombreuses joueuses professionnelles
comme faits réels ben hassen 17 ans qui
s'entraîne au club de gaz elec à tunis
qui m'inspire le plus chez elle c'est
son mental sa persévérance sa motivation
sa sa façon d'être sur le terrain ça
donne plus espoir en espoir pour les
jeunes joueuses que ces basses et
accessible d'arriver au top top 10 ou
encore top 5
le phénomène ne s'arrête pas aux
joueuses lors du tournoi masculin de
tunis open organisé par le tennis club
de tunis en mai dernier les spectateurs
ne parlait que donne ce toutes
générations confondues j'aime bien la
regarder dans ce match parce que sam
apprend beaucoup
c'est là un point de nouvelles tactiques
alors j'ai d'abord si tu es ma fierté
pour la femme tunisienne et pour la
femme arabe au sein du club le nombre de
pratiquants a doublé et le nombre de
filles inscrites a augmenté de 30% la
fédération de tennis veut profiter de
l'élan donné par ron ce pour
démocratiser ce sport dans tout le pays
en a des clubs à tozeur en avec bach
être béja et l'objectif phare de la
fédération c'est de rendre de ce sport
un sport populaire et d'essayer de
d'enlever ce slogan de sport de
bourgeois dans la continuité du succès
d'un labeur entourent n'avait t avais
être organisé en tunisie en octobre
prochain dans la ville de monastir une
première dans le pays
c'est sur ces images que nous refermons
ce journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis et en particulier
ceux de tunis à lomé en passant par
niamey restez avec nous car l'actualité
continuation
[Musique]
la culture à l'heure française
musique cinéma littérature mode
gastronomie toute l'actualité des
festivals des expositions et des
spectacles de l'hexagone et du monde à
la fiche présenté par louis dupont à
voir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme
[Musique]